Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny is
about to hit theaters we're on the
street asking folks are you excited to
see this
[Music]
I love Indiana Jones I love it since I
was little I was there from day one I
saw the original in the theaters before
you were born I'm sure I am a huge in
the Jones fan since the 80s so I'm so
excited and I'm so excited to introduce
him to Indiana Jones it just kind of
reminds me of my childhood you know like
I would always watch those movies
growing up so I'm very excited for the
new one the first movie is my favorite
movie of all time so I am very much the
demographic for this I mean I stopped
watching after the first one so after
after Raiders of the Lost
cement
come on long table has John Williams
doing the music I'm good do you really
like Phoebe Waller Bridge so he's in the
new one yeah I hope I don't get Crystal
scold this time and I hope it's a little
bit better but I'm a little optimistic
James mangle is a great director so it's
so crazy how something so old can still
be brought up to our generation today it
has that connection with families as
well so I enjoy that I'm gonna love this
movie for sure gonna be so cool to see
see how they tie things together how
they wrap it up have you heard of
Indiana Jones that you've seen any of
those movies not really okay do you know
who stars in it no all right we got a
lot of work to do with you you stole it
then you stole it
and then I stole it it's called
capitalism
[Music]
Harrison Ford is 80 years old still
playing Indiana Jones you think he can
pull it off one more time I think so
yeah yeah he's 80. wow no yeah I think
he looks good I think he could do it I
just heard a shock when you heard he was
80 years old
he's good look at Sylvester Stallone oh
definitely that's his role that doesn't
stop him playing Indiana Jones from the
previews and the trailers that we saw
man Harrison Ford still got it yes he
can pull it off of course he's going to
be perfect I've heard in interviews that
they're kind of incorporating his age
into a little more than they did in the
last one some CGI work too but other
than that yeah it works great for him
too yeah works for him as well you know
we could all use a little CGI in our
older years right please give me a line
for that I dare say uh 80 year old
Harrison Ford is not going to get you
back in the theater for a new Indiana
Jones movie
all right because why old people can't
go search for Treasure I mean they are a
treasure so you know
Tomatoes at all Stark Raiders of the
Lost Ark the original is always the best
I mean you can't beat a giant boulder
chasing after you and you know nothing
beats that can anybody name the first
movie in the Indiana Jones franchise is
it the one where he was in a fridge and
like a nuke went off or something like
put your hands down wait you're
embarrassing us the temple Doom I really
like the Temple of Doom actually that
one's really good Temple of Doom there
it is that's because it opens with Kate
Capshaw singing Anything Goes in
Mandarin and as a musical theater fan my
gosh you know that's incredible it was
so scary because they were doing a
sacrificing and stuff yeah that was
probably the scariest of all the movies
and that's your favorite yeah that was
my favorite when I was younger I was not
allowed to watch that far I had to cover
my eyes so I still cover my eyes that's
scary man so you saw Temple at Doom that
one freak out a little bit no not really
you're a bravery guy than I am yeah
Indiana Jones and the Last
yeah
it was that last airbender
sorry it was a joke everybody's lost
with me the Last Crusade uh Last Crusade
the beginning was those young Indy and
at the end they're right off into the
sunset perfect ending I hate when they
cut that off when I'm watching it on
cable let Indy and his friends right off
into the sunset right like into like a
little small box in the corner and let
the credits go like super fast so you
really can't hear the music it's the
kingdom of Crystal Skull so yeah that's
your favorite Indiana Jones movie
because of my age I would say crystal
skull that was like the biggest biggest
one that had the most impact for me
finish this one at least Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny there we go get
back
and now it's your turn comment let us
know are you excited to see Indiana
Jones what about dial of Destiny is
getting you back in the theater that's
all for on the street I'm Mark Ellis and
we'll see you next time at Rotten
Tomatoes after you see Indiana Jones in
the dial of Destiny make sure you rate
and review at Rotten Tomatoes say uh
man you got good Security today Ellen
why are we not talking about the little
mermaid in the Barbie movie here did you
like the new Little Mermaid movie I
didn't see it yet